[Música]
saludamos a toda nuestra audiencia
muchísimas gracias por continuar en la
pantalla de france 24 estamos de regreso
con este programa especial dedicado a la
noticia que marca absolutamente esta
jornada y que como ven no sólo haití
sino también a todo el mundo es que el
presidente haitiano yo ven el móvil de
53 años fue asesinado por un grupo de
hombres armados durante la madrugada de
este miércoles en su residencia su
esposa martín móvil fue herida y
permanece hospitalizada en estos
momentos horas después de ese ataque el
primer ministro interino cloud joseph
declaró el estado de sitio en todo el
país y para analizar esta noticia
llevarles toda la información lo más
actualizada mente posible nos acompañan
robinson inglés y él es analista
político y también activista por los
derechos humanos y saludamos también a
louis jean pierre loris ton doctor en
ciencia política y administración
pública les agradecemos muchísimo su
presencia en este programa especial de
france 24 dedicado a esta trágica
noticia que se acude como decíamos a
haití a todo el mundo del presidente
de haití joven el mainz fue asesinado
durante esta madrugada por hombres
armados y si le parece comenzamos con un
informe para conocer más de cerca quién
fue rubén el mois el fallecido
presidente de haití recordemos que nació
un 26 de junio de 1968 y estuvo cinco
años al mando de esta nación caribeña y
lo hizo en medio de un contexto de
inestabilidad política y también social
y económica nuestra compañera alba
santana nos entrega un perfil del
fallecido mandatario cuya muerte hoy
conmociona a todo el mundo
hasta el 2015 el exportador de plátanos
siempre salió joven el mois nunca había
ocupado un cargo político año en el que
a pesar de ser poco conocido por el
público general el haitiano se lanzó
como candidato a la presidencia con el
partido ph teca una opción de centro
derecha el empresario consiguió ganar
las elecciones generales del octubre de
ese año con el 32 8% de los votos pero
los comicios fueron invalidados por
irregularidades y no fue hasta febrero
de 2017 que chove en el match juró el
cargo y se convirtió en el presidente
del país más pobre de américa desde
entonces
haití ya se estaba encaminando hacia una
crisis política y social que no le
pondría las cosas fáciles al recién
nombrado mandatario con miles de
personas en las calles desde mediados de
2018 la crisis alcanzó su punto álgido
el 7 de febrero de este año cuando el
dirigente acusó a la oposición de estar
tramando un golpe de estado con el apoyo
de algunos jueces sus desertores
sostenían que su mandato terminaba en
febrero de 2021
cuando se en que este había empezado
antes de jurar el cargo en medio de una
época políticamente convulsa haití
enfrenta un gran problema de seguridad
el poder de las bandas criminales ha
aumentado con la crisis política y los
índices de secuestros y la criminalidad
están disparados por eso muy sin tentó
frenar el descontento social y las
protestas impulsando un referendo para
votar una nueva constitución el próximo
26 de septiembre y buscó apoyos
internacionales como el de eeuu para
permanecer en la presidencia el político
de 53 años terminaba su mandato en
febrero de 2022 avanzamos en este
programa especial de france 24 dedicado
al asesinato del presidente de haití job
en el mois volvemos a saludar a nuestros
invitados especiales saludamos
nuevamente a robben song lazy lee
también a luis jean pierre loris ton
comenzamos con ustedes señor héctor
vuelvo agradecerles su presencia en
france 24 preguntarle que representaba
no móvil para haití como definiría a
usted lo que fue su gestión
y yo buenas buenas buenos días o buenas
tardes yo y yo destino a johann moritz
no tanto ayer mermó y si no las
decisiones que él estaba tomando como si
fuera las mismas decisiones que tomaba
la sangre salín el padre de la nación
ojo yo no estoy comparando lo mermó is
con de salir yo no estoy haciendo eso
sería una pretensión muy mala pero las
decisiones que estaba tomando
últimamente cuando se trata de
corrupción cuando se trata de unos
proyectos y el otro también tenemos de
dónde sale sale un poquito más o menos
de estos mismos raíces del pueblo del
pueblo donde los
las oligarquías del país no pueden
aguantar una figura como el geo final
móvil lo que en haití desde 1801 o antes
llamamos un anterior imagínense nosotros
llamamos a la gente del país gente de
fuera o sea una de lo anterior significa
gente de fuera
saludamos nuevamente al señor robinson
inglés y se encuentra en buenos aires la
capital de la república argentina bueno
y xavi ha denunciado varias amenazas a
su gobierno en febrero por ejemplo
denunció que se estaba tramando una
suerte de golpe de estado en su contra
había además anunciado la detención de
más de 20 personas no a las que acusó de
intentar atentar contra su vida y
derrocar a su gobierno fueron detenidos
de hecho un juez de la corte suprema por
ejemplo quien hacía parte de toda una
lista no de posibles sucesores del
presidente estamos ingresando quizás en
un terreno un poco especulativo no pero
qué figuras podrían evaluarse como
posibles que elementos que estén detrás
no de este ataque
perdón hacemos una corrección no se
encuentra en buenos aires- se encuentra
en la ciudad de rosario
muy buenas tardes les saludo desde el
rosario es una pregunta muy compleja en
el sentido que en haití en la vida
política 10 de años y años siempre fue
muy compleja y muy complicada un ejemplo
muy claro de nuestra independencia en
1804 hasta el día de hoy
un 25 por ciento de los jefes de estados
de haití pudieron terminar su mandato
sabemos que estamos en una espiral de
inestabilidad crónica en el caso del ex
presidente robert weiss en dentro de la
vida política desde como lo podía llamar
un outsider era un empresario y un
hombre de negocios que no estaba muy
activo en la vida política ahora tenemos
que entender que los políticos haitianos
nunca tuvieron un compromiso con el
experto de la democracia lo podemos
decir
incluso el ex presidente lo del molise
también no tienen ese compromiso con la
democracia porque siempre lo que quieren
es buscar derrotar al otro para poder
estar en su espacio y justamente lo que
estamos tratando de denunciar que el que
tiene que seguir o entablar el camino
hacia la democracia lamentablemente es
una situación
y como joven
nunca vivimos una situación así porque
vivimos golpe de estado pero ver un
presidente asesinado no nunca haremos
eso la última vez fue en el año 1915 por
eso hoy el pueblo está un poquito estar
muy y ahora señores yo no vuelvo a
saludarlo tenía varios frentes abiertos
no el fallecido mandatario de haití mons
y estuvo en el centro de muchísimas
polémicas verdades los líderes
opositores estaban pidiendo su dimisión
argumentando que su mandato
combinaba legalmente en febrero de 2021
esto era cinco años después de las
elecciones de 2016 sino en 2022 como
defendía al fallecido presidente y
también sus partidarios o sea el
contexto era bastante complejo en el que
se produjo su asesinato
a mí sí sí sí sí
no lo que lo que la polémica que el
presidente difunto presidente era que él
reclamaba los reclamos las reclamaciones
eran justa por ejemplo si uno mira el
gobierno del estado estaba pagando por
electricidad algo a unos empresarios que
cobraron que cobraban millones de
dólares por muchos años para
electricidad pero la electricidad que
nunca existió nunca existió todos socias
intereses hace que el presidente era el
enemigo número uno del ex de la
oposición pero luego también hablando de
oposición
en haití siempre ha sido así el día
siguiente a elección es el que pierde
normalmente nunca acepte que pierde las
elecciones normalmente siempre tratan de
hacer cualquier cosa para evitar que el
otro tenga éxito
ellos lo miran como si fuera el éxito
del del ganador es el éxito de él ellos
no miran que el éxito del ganador es el
éxito de un país por eso mismo como
había dicho mi compatriota anteriormente
el problema en haití no platica hoy es
un problema cultural que tenemos desde
antes de 1804 donde los hombres que
gobiernan el país siempre tratan de
gobernar lo como si fuera una
una reina hits o como si fuera una como
una cosa como los reyes y es lo mismo
que hizo el emperador zhu zhenyu de
hecho hizo lo mismo
o sea blooming es que la democracia para
ellos está acusando existe significa que
yo tengo que estar en el poder cuando no
estoy yo pongo a mi esposa cuando no
está mi esposa yo pongo a mi hijo eso es
el problema que tenemos en haití que hay
que a ver analizamos con sus
palabras no existiría no de acuerdo a
ustedes lo que sería una fuerte
tradición democrática no en haití esto
se traduciría tanto en acciones por
parte de los diversos gobiernos
recordemos que también haití ha sufrido
más de 20 golpes de estado muchísimos de
ellos exitosos pero no sólo se
traduciría en una suerte de falta de
conciencia democrática crea usted en el
gobierno sino también en el resto de los
sectores de la sociedad verdad y este
hecho de tanta violencia es producto es
una manifestación de quizás esa suerte
de falta de cultura democrática o es uno
de sus aspectos por lo menos
mira muy buena pregunta si uno mira la
historia de esta isla la violencia no
empieza hoy la violencia todos los que
estudiamos historia muchas veces nos
muestran una cara de punto en la
historia por tan pobre anna de otro otro
tipo de haití pero la violencia que
existía antes hace que nosotros en haití
y la cultura democrática que debería ser
sobre todo por la educación nunca
existió
salvo salvo en un tiempo 1860 más o
menos durante el gobierno de jefa
durante el gobierno deje fue más o menos
conocimos una estabilidad donde hay una
continuidad porque por una sencilla
razón la educación la educación por
mabel pero desde un principio si uno
mira la educación en haití cuando de
salir por supuesto yo tengo todo el
respeto por de salir pero
las únicas seis escuelas que existía
durante el régimen de salir estaba
dentro de los cantones militares qué
significa esto
entiendo que de salem quería pues llevar
a los militares para una posible regreso
de francia pero qué pasa con los demás
la ciudadanía que quería educarse y eso
siempre ha sido así por eso mismo una
cosa que le va a adicionar antes de
terminar
tuvimos que esperar 175 años
voy a seguir 175 años después de la
independencia para reconocer el creo que
habla mi abuela que habla mis abuelos el
peor como idioma hablado en el país
cuando 90% de la población habla creo
90 por 90 de actuación eso todas estas
cosas son indicios que hace que no
tenemos la cultura que no estamos a la
altura y tenemos que pensar como nación
señor robinson inglés y le estábamos
hablando sobre esta suerte de buenas
hipótesis no de una especie de falta de
cultura democrática en haití es un país
que vive una creciente ola de violencia
verdad usted cree que esto es producto
bueno esto es una manifestación más no
de la violencia que se vive en haití
pero una manifestación muy extrema
estamos hablando de un magnicidio
coincide usted con este análisis con
esta suerte de falta de conciencia y de
cultura democrática en el país que se
traduce en este tipo de hechos
bien primero creo que debemos tomar el
tiempo para entender que la crisis que
vive mi país y mi nación no es algo y
abstracta no es algo metafísica existe
en esencia en el hombre es por ejemplo
si después de la independencia de ahí
tiene el año 304 unos años después
haití fue ocupado por eeuu a partir del
año 1915 hasta el año 1930 y cuatro años
después a partir de 1957 hasta el 86 29
años de dictadura hay desde 1804 tuvimos
nuestras primeras elecciones
democráticas en el año 1990
somos una nación un joven clave en este
sentido tan los los dirigentes ya
tenemos esa práctica de detener y
militares en el poder
y fíjate en el primer presidente
democrático del país fue derrocado siete
meses después de asumir el poder un
golpe de estado apoyado también por
potencias internacionales hay que decir
eso perdiendo esas potencias no ayudan a
que haití será una nación democrática el
ex presidente fallecido bueno ya se
aprueba le dijo claramente a un ex
funcionario de presidente de las
naciones unidas en haití el señor edward
mohler no quería debutar en el poder lo
que iba a sacar en el poder entonces
cómo vamos a ayudar a esa nación para
seguir adelante
yo lo que creo primero los responsables
los primeros responsables son los
haitianos que tenemos que armarnos de
fuerza para seguir el camino de la
justicia el término más ángel espeto de
los derechos humanos que ningún gobierno
incluso el gobierno desde el presidente
fallecido por el móvil no tuvo ese
compromiso con el pueblo haitiano hace
unos días en el barrio donde yo nací
hombres motorizados
alrededor de 20 personas esto es algo
que pasó hace menos dos semanas incluso
que un periodista ha hallado una
militante feminista que lo mataron
también dentro de su auto estamos
hablando en esta situación que el
gobierno actual este gobierno por
ejemplo las masacres que tuvo que
cumplir que pasaron en muchos barrios
del país el gobierno nunca dijo nada
nunca levantó la mano para decir basta
no hay un compromiso parece que nos
vamos a erradicar esta inseguridad
crónica que está matando al país el
presidente fallecido donde al morir el
durante su campaña electoral fue uno de
los pocos candidatos que pudo entrar en
uno de los barrios más picantes del país
acompañado de un jefe de banda armada no
sé cómo vamos a hablar de democracia en
un contexto así como podríamos hablar de
democracia cuando los dirigentes
políticos que sea de la oposición puede
al gobierno de facto actual
s esa connivencia con los grupos armados
estamos hablando de una nación en un
término de su superficie en haití está
circulando a seguros los informes de
algunas organismos de derechos humanos y
mientras en el armas en un país tan
pequeño funcionan más de 70 bandas
hermanas conivencia con los dirigentes
políticos así que en este camino es muy
difícil y estar en una situación de
democracia hoy en día a mi país todo
está viviendo en democracia no con este
gobierno pero hace años entonces lo que
yo quiero como ciudadano a interno como
joven haitiano es ese compromiso de los
dirigentes políticos con la de educación
ese compromiso con el pueblo haitiano
para respetar los derechos humanos de la
gente de mi país es lo que queremos y es
un camino bastante largo porque tenemos
enemigos internos que son los propios
haitianos los otros dirigentes y
enemigos externo
y que nos ayuden a haití para poder
estar entrar en el camino hacia la
democracia cuando habla de enemigos
externos a quienes se refiere
puntualmente y qué rol cree que debería
ocupar la comunidad internacional por
ejemplo el presidente de colombiano iván
duque llamo a la organización de estados
américanos a que intervenga de manera
urgente
perfecto me parece bien tener este tipo
de apoyo pero sí pero en que porque hay
una gran diferencia entre decirlo y
pasar a la práctica porque cuando pasan
y esa una relación sistemática de
derechos humanos que en mi país no veo
esos dirigentes se decir que el pueblo
haitiano tiene que caminar el pueblo la
vida en haití tiene que tener el sentido
porque cuando yo hablo con mis amigos en
haití las digo siempre tengan cuidado me
responden eso si tenemos cuidado pero no
podemos hacer nada sabemos que podemos
salir pero no sabemos que no vamos a
entrar cuando tienes un país y en muchas
zonas y muchas zonas dentro del país
está en manos de bandas hermanas no
podemos hablar de democracia y que hace
esos representantes de esas
organizaciones internacionales no ayudan
pertenecía recién que el ex
representante de las ars unidas en haití
ni al serio que le hizo debutar a el
presidente préval
los hechos están tenemos siempre
para salvar a haití primero eso depende
de los haitianos y las haitianas primero
después si algunas naciones quieren
ayudar que en él colaboran y vamos a ver
cómo se puede hacerlo pero hay que hace
años porque sirve como pendiente nuestra
independencia la forma en que accedemos
a nuestra independencia fue algo
bastante imputó a para el mundo de hoy
porque una pequeña nación así tuvo esa
forma y de independencia realizar una
independencia antes la bajista
antirracista anticolonialista pero que
haití hasta el día de hoy no creen como
esa parte de los ss como el país
incómodo en la historia de la humanidad
está bien que las organizaciones
internacionales
estoy viendo lo que no por lo que pasó
hoy y es la que con el fallecimiento con
el asesinato del presidente pero quieren
que ésta este compromiso presente con el
pueblo haitiano más que nada
ahora como veníamos diciendo es
inevitable hablar por supuesto del
contexto en el que se produce el
asesinato del presidente haitiano yo en
el mont porque se da en medio de una
fuertísima y también histórica como
decían nuestros invitados crisis
política social y también económica y
cultural verdad sobre la que vamos a
profundizar en el siguiente informe en
el que tenemos preparado veamos este
informe sobre el contexto en el que se
dio el asesinato del presidente haitiano
joven el movice
haití primer país independiente de
américa latina y actualmente también el
más pobre de la región 11,2 millones de
habitantes viven en este país arrasado
en los últimos años por un terremoto en
2010 y el huracán matthew en 2016 tras
ambos desastres el país recibió gran
cantidad de ayuda internacional que ha
estado rodeada de interrogantes la deuda
externa del país superaba el 36 por
ciento en 2020 y la supuesta ayuda
internacional a haití más dependiente
del exterior la pobreza arrasa a la
población haitiana los sueños de la
revolución de esclavos que la llevó a la
independencia nunca se cumplieron se
calcula que más del 20 por ciento de la
población vive bajo el umbral de la
extrema pobreza en este contexto la
crisis derivada de la pandemia de kobe
19 sólo ha empeorado la situación hay
una crisis humanitaria con escasez de
alimentos y haití es de los pocos países
del mundo que no ha recibido ninguna
dosis de la vacuna a todo esto se le
suma la crisis política que estalló en
2015 hubo comicios en los que ganó job
en el mois el mandatario y asesinado
pero no fue reconocido por la autoridad
electoral hasta
después allí comenzó la controversia
para moix en este momento comenzaba su
mandato para la oposición un año antes
así moix defendía que su mandato
acabaría en 2022 cuando no se
presentaría a las elecciones el
parlamento está disuelto por decreto
desde enero de 2020 y la oposición ya no
reconocía la legitimidad de moix que
gobernaba ahora por decreto en febrero
de este año las calles estallaron en
protestas en esa fecha según la
oposición moix debería haber entregado
el poder desde entonces el gobierno de
maurice detuvo a 20 opositores por
supuesto golpismo que más tarde fueron
absueltos por un tribunal móvil se había
declarado enemigo de la oligarquía que
controla los negocios claves como la
banca o la energía en un país que ha
sufrido el gran aumento del precio de
los combustibles ha grabado también por
la falta de envío de crudo desde
venezuela su otrora principal proveedor
las bandas siembran también al país de
violencia y se calcula que controlan
hasta el 60 por ciento del territorio
sólo durante este pasado junio ha muerto
más de 150 personas y otras 200 han sido
secuestradas en el área metropolitana de
puerto príncipe
y que ha tenido más de 20 gobiernos en
35 años por el momento nadie ha
conseguido la estabilidad
veamos un informe que hacía referencia y
que explicaba no en profundidad lo que
es la durísima crisis política social
económica cultural y de todas las áreas
en el país en la república de haití y
quisiera preguntarle ahora al señor lo
visto si considera que este hecho no el
asesinato del fallecido mandatario
maurice viene a profundizar todavía más
la crisis que vive el país
yo creo que sí yo creo que sí por una
sencilla razón porque la constitución
normalmente cuando el presidente no
puede ejercer su función la constitución
tendría que entrar a decir quién el el
juez que debería tomar en el puesto que
debería convertirse como presidente ya
no existe
yo en junio pasado debido al coronavirus
entonces esa semana hubo una expulsión
un nuevo primer ministro para cómo
llevar las negociaciones para llevar las
cosas que las reclamaciones los reclamos
de la oposición pero
murió el presidente esta mañana pero
quien garantiza quién está garantizado
el la la adquisición pública quien está
sacando los comunicados como como como
digo yo el que emplaza al presidente
estamos hablando del primer ministro que
estaba antes del que nombraron entonces
ya entramos en una crisis peor porque
porque no tiene a ciencia cierta quién
debe reemplazar el presidente fallecido
ahora bien yo creo la razón por la cual
yo le digo yo no creo que las ojalá que
me equivoco la razón por la cual yo digo
que eso se va a empeorar porque porque
los que van a tratar de reemplazar el
gobierno son los que tienen más poder de
fuego más
un día más
y más criminales detrás de ellos son
ellos que van a poder dirigir hay una
cosa que yo digo a los haitianos que es
muy importante pero yo soy haitiano a
mis compatriotas y evitar evitar está
google estos gobiernos posicionales hay
que seguir con la misma agenda que tenía
el gobierno yo tengo ir a hacer las
elecciones no colocar un una un gobierno
funcional para empezar otra vez las
corrupciones todas las conducciones que
se han hecho en el país se hicieron
sobre todo durante gobiernos función yo
no estoy diciendo que no hay
corrupciones en los gobiernos como yo
tenemos no estoy diciendo esto pero la
provisionalidad de los gobiernos eso
ayuda mucho a desestabilizar
y
debilitar a debilitar las instituciones
en el país se abre entonces para usted
un periodo de mayor violencia política y
social entonces cómo evitarla cómo
garantizar no la democracia la
gobernabilidad y el estado de derecho en
haití
mira yo creo que eeuu tiene un gol por
supuesto a quien diría pero porque estoy
diciendo eeuu eso yo estoy y no es que
me gusta que estado pues venga ahí y
ocupa el país como lo hicieron en varias
ocasiones por ejemplo una de las cosas
que yo siempre digo los haitianos que un
de haití en la pobreza fue la
constitución de 1810 y 8 es otro tema
que cambiaron un artículo que que
evitaba que podía que los extranjeros
hablando en el extranjero sobre todo
tendría que decirlo los blancos
extranjeros no podían tener propiedades
en el país era para evitar que los
campesinos era para volver era para
promocionar a los campesinos que tengan
terreno para la cultura para cultivar
porque era la riqueza del campesino y
después vienen los cerdos pero eso es
otra discusión de la pobreza pero
desafortunadamente yo digo
desafortunadamente para mí va a jugar un
lugar muy importante eeuu en
supuestamente estabilizar haití o sea
ellos van a entrar
normalmente los pandillas mira lo que
pasa en haití cuando los estados llegan
en reality para tratar de establecer el
la paz o supuestamente la paz la
tranquilidad las pandillas tienen miedo
de extradición
como tienen miedo de es tradición y lo
otro también la mayoría de los hijos de
ellos la esposa de ellos la familia de
ellos viven en eeuu
entonces como esta sociedad los tienen
los tienen identificados ellos
normalmente que hacen si eeuu llegan a
cómo pacificar el país ellos de una vez
bajan las armas durante el tiempo que
eeuu y esta prevención no quiere decir
perdón que se interrumpa robinson
quisiera preguntarle por el futuro que
se abre según usted a partir de ahora en
haití considera que será un futuro más
violento que escenarios podrían prever
se y cómo podría garantizarse también la
gobernabilidad de este país no
creo que y
antes de hablar del futuro o sea estamos
en una situación de violencia hace unos
años bastante fuertes hay que hablar del
futuro de cómo que el presente ya está
bastante tranquilo el presente y ahí en
este momento está muy muy triste pero me
refiero a las consecuencias del
asesinato no del presidente al futuro
inmediato digamos como consecuencia del
asesinato de moix
si estamos estamos en una situación de
confusión más bastante fuerte lo que
queremos o lo que yo pienso es saber lo
que pasó es exactamente porque el ex
presidente fue una de las personas con
mayor seguridad en todo el país si un
grupo armados pudieron entrar a su casa
sin el nodo de respuesta de sus agentes
de seguridad pero que hay algo que
debemos pensar como cómo pasó él como
suyo y esas cosas quién tiene la
responsabilidad eso lo tenemos que saber
y el pueblo haitiano tiene que tener
esas respuestas el futuro haitiano el
futuro de mi país está muy incierto pero
generalmente o no te puede decir lo que
se puede lo que puede pasar en unas
semanas en unas horas o en unos años
pero que ya el futuro de mi país está
bastante comprometido y bastante oscuro
ahora es interesante lo que plantea
usted no porque se abre también el
interrogante sobre el accionar no en el
entorno en lo que es la seguridad
presidencial verdad
pero totalmente el presidente tiene
puestas sedes en seguridad a su
alrededor de todo el tiempo
como podemos imaginar semejante cosas
veo a un par de vídeos no puedo
y dar el cien por ciento porque no tengo
informaciones oficiales en el momento
pero esto necesitamos respuestas de
parte del actuar el director de la
policía nacional del actual primer
ministro interino necesitamos respuestas
necesitamos respuestas del jefe de la
seguridad presidencial porque mismo este
mismo jefe que hace unos meses estaba en
casa en el de los medios de comunicación
para decir que él evitó el golpe de
estado que querían dar al actual legal
presidente sobre el país pero
necesitamos ahora es escuchado para
saber qué pasó exactamente porque la
violencia no va a llevar a haití en
ningún espacio puedes estar día puedes
estar de acuerdo o no con este gobierno
con el presidente bueno pero no la
violencia no es el camino para el cambio
de haití la violencia que es el camino
hacia
la democracia para refuerzos así que
necesitamos respuesta nos llamamos un
silencio
no necesitamos que nos digan vamos a
seguir buscando quién es rico quién lo
fue no necesitamos respuesta y que por
una vez por todas que el pueblo haitiano
tenga acceso o pueda leer la verdad para
seguir avanzando bueno estamos llegando
ya al final de este programa especial
dedicado a la trágica noticia que
conmociona a haití ya todo el mundo que
es el asesinato del presidente de chopin
el moisés ocurrido durante la madrugada
de este hombre en su propia vivienda
cuando fue invadida por hombres armados
estaremos instruyéndoles toda la
información a lo largo de la continua de
informativa de france 24 agradecemos una
vez más a los invitados que tuvieron
viernes participando de este programa
especial trayéndonos todo su análisis de
robben singles de iglesia y también se
amplió lo visto muchísimas gracias por
su presencia en este programa especial
de france 24 ya nuestra audiencia
continúen informando se en el resto de
nuestra
en france 24 punto com sigan con
nosotros
[Música]